Hi, this is Mike.
I was just calling to see if
that job that you offered was
still available.
Yes, the security guard.
I will take anything.
This place was huge in
the 80's with the kids.
They shut it down years ago.
The owner's just not
ready to let it go yet.
I will work, and
you will sleep.
I understand.
Gimme your hand.
All you have to do is keep
your eyes on the monitor.
Welcome to Freddy Fazbear's!
Where fantasy and
fun come to life!
Okay.
You must be,
new security guard.
Can I, uh, help you, officer?
Have you met them yet?
Met who?
Them.
In the 80's,
kids went missing.
The police searched
Freddy's top to bottom.
Hello?
They never found them.
It's why the place shut down.
There are ghost children
possessing giant robots?
Thanks for the heads up.
Technically, they're
animatronics.
What do they want?
They want to make
her, like them.
Abby!
Tell me how to stop them!
[ giggling ]
[ scream ]
It's too late.
Mike!
-Abby go!
[ scream ]
Where to?
Why do I always
get the weirdos?